welcome to this video playing as per
week neck a spear Rick neck from the
Netherlands and the King's gambit oh
come on let's have some fun with 95 95
96 and f5 this is what I'm trying to say
the Adelaide counter gambit a wacky
opening but funny opening I always like
to play this in bullet so leading to too
funny play hmm did I already do
something wrong here no I know I can do
d 585 at age 60 how was the service
displayed how is displayed
yeah i think if de for and age 60 m yeah
i don't know i usually only play this
and click on time controls it's a it's
not so bad but it's of course a very
very extreme position but I can't go
here isn't this quite okay I mean night
takes is got the check on age five I
don't want that I'm irritated that he's
playing so quickly check you know this
this can mean various things that he
doesn't care about the position just
wants to win on time that he knows it
and it's bad for me that he is less
everything possible f5 though looks
completely crazy how does he protects
you to know I mean I was far better
developed any way I can get get the rock
now and there come on it's a rook or not
or not i mean if i go here how does what
what does he play a piece values is
behind if you move the piece i can just
play three king you want i just go back
and have grabbed the spawn and it's the
same situation again if i take here yeah
i can i can take that one check so
wonder I've gettin too I've got the two
pawns and now I can
safely and even more conveniently win
the rook yeah not sure maybe he's drunk
early in the morning it's a chat
slightly after afternoon my time and
also Dutch time white resigned he had no
idea what he was doing this is an
opening that might confuse you but still
I'm I read all I have big big
development here but let's say let's say
here this is probably good to get rid of
this night the night that was
threatening to enter the game and this
should be okay really funny computer
suggestion kingi seven to get the pawn
and now it wants to play this which is
really funny black has a terrible
structure but active pieces Jeff maybe
this is equal I don't know depends on
very concrete factors how much this
activity is good actually yeah but I
don't think it's Sam it's not bad for
black I really don't know what's the
what's the best line for for white and
this in this opening this is some this
is known but even if we look at it I
played age six but even this isn't so
clear check something like that I mean
I'm probably getting a five not not bad
the night on d8 covers the sense of TV 6
square yeah five is a wacky line but not
it's not so bad
there are some sources that claim that
d3 is right this was even played in a
game between Iran shook and nakamura i'm
not sure who about the color
distribution both players i think that
camera was black but it could easily be
the other of other way around they both
are players that like to experiment in
the opening and if it's not completely
unsound they are willing to try some
things okay a strange game but thanks
for watching